bon bah voilà le moment donc où
j'accueille rachid djaïdani que vous ne
connaissez pas je vous montrais son
livre donc ça s'appelle bunker on en est
à 40 mille exemplaires d'un livre très
étonnant très bien écrit le personnage
de l'est pas moins donc vous allez faire
connaître quelqu'un que vous ne
connaissez pas rachid djaïdani
bonsoir voisine bachelot député rpr mes
repères coulin valérie lemercier
chantilly pascal légitimus
on se connaît on vous connaissez ouais
j'ai connu mes cheveux un peu plus long
ah ben voilà et - écrivain témoins
décrivent un hic est que que vous
connaissez alors rachid on vous a
demandé de venir parce que vous êtes un
personnage étonnant votive dont boom
coeur que je montre à la caméra comme ça
commence à la télé zoom zoom bon garçon
voilà un zoom zoom zoom mon garçon joue
quand c'est pas 4 0 c'est mieux dans le
bunker 40000 exemplaires
ouais c'est bien alors pour moi moi
voilà moi en fait ce que j'aime dans ce
livre c'est pas un livre qui raconte
face à raconte les sites etc
mais c'est pas que ça parce que ça sinon
ça serait un livre de sociologie ça sera
un livre de témoignages une grecque
c'est super bien écrit je te remercie
non mais c'est vrai alors ce que je
voudrais qu'on fasse simplement si vous
pouviez lire la quatrième de couverture
ouais parce que comme ça on va voir tout
de suite c'est c'est des phrases un peu
comme dans le rap ça c'est des phrases
qui tourne c'est on sent quand on
contacte un coup alors voilà quand on le
vit quand on lui a demandé ça quand on
le lit on entend on entend une musique
ça tourne alors juste la quatrième de
couverture tout va bien bazire a chip tu
me dis go j'te dis ok mon âgés de 21 et
verts s'est improvisé je précise
ouais ok mon âge est de 21 hiver je
porte un jeans 501 un pull bleu son
poignet droit
une gourmette en argent avec le prénom
d'un mail mot des femmes qui frangin
j'habite au deuxième étage d'une tour
d'une des tours de la cité
je suis au chômage j'aime bien la vie en
général mais j'aime pas le rap des
variétés qui me parle de bouger de là et
qui me dit de me balancer les bras en
l'air parce que ma vie et funky je suis
un requin assassin face à la mention de
mou phrasé j'aime bien les gens sincères
qui défendent des causes sociales
j'aime pas sos racisme il vient dans nos
quartiers c'est uniquement lorsque ces
problèmes sur le dos de nos cadavres qui
font du mat et enfin j'aime bien les
grands frères du quartier qui préfèrent
toucher leur rmi plutôt qu'en filet des
rangers
pour surveiller des magasins qui
n'appartient même pas leur père je me
planque avec mon pote grésy qui a commis
une bêtise à la sortie d'une école trois
points de suspension
je fermais dit mais où sont nos repères
qui se nouent modèle de toute une
jeunesse vous voulez les rêves voulait
les haines brisé les rêves targue la
salle de l'espérance suprême ntm ses
premiers romans récits de rachid el hani
25 piges et caractère sérieusement ça
tourne ça tourne très bien il ya du
style comme vous dites
dissidia du style il ya du style non
c'est vrai c'est très très bien merci
alors ya juste un petit problème il ya
deux ans c'était trop bon on y arrive à
la norme asie sa cigarette c'est pas toi
c'est pas vu c'est le seuil il ya deux
fautes d'orthographe
page 14 juin je m'étais fait confisquer
et passe 86 il s'était fait carotter et
les changer d'éditeur
alors je suis un effet pour dire
regardez ces banlieues il peut vouloir
chasser vous c'est un honnêtement qu'ils
aient fait des fautes ou pas de faute la
profondeur à aller dans l'histoire ouais
après c'est superficiel d'accord mais où
alors c'est un moyen pour vérifier si
l'animateur a lu le bouquin
non c'est un jeu en fait un jeu
radiophonique mais là tu as donné toutes
les réponses donc faire le bouquin et
plusieurs fautes et comme ça en mettra
si si jamais tu avais lu le récit à
l'origine c'était pire c'était beaucoup
plus placé les deux mois qu'ils ont pas
enlevé en fait voilà enfin c'est un
cadeau qui m'ont fait bon il m'a dit mon
quartier mais si la lumière on va passer
à l'hyper view donc voila merci c'est
lorsqu'elles font alors au sol quand ils
ont su le manuscrit ils sont dix ils ont
eu peur qui est un [ __ ] en fait parce
qu'ils se sont dit ah je suis vexé on
parle toujours de moi ça mais non parce
que il y arrive ce qui est sorti charbon
il ya deux ans qui s'appelait lille a10
a6 nouchi mot qu'elle a été écrit en
fait par des gens je dis pas comme vous
et moi mais comme vous et moi et qui
n'était en fait qu'une à la manière de
quand ils ont peur que c'était écrit par
par un parent par quelqu un par un par
un [ __ ]
ils ont détruit ce fut écrit ce fut
écrit par écrit
ce fut écrit mais ce que j'ai pu parler
et vous vous rachid nous vivons c'est
bien vous qui l'avez grille vous dites
vous dit quand vous parlez du bouquin
vous dites je savais que je leur avais
donné un beau caillou assez clair c'est
clair la preuve aujourd'hui quand mille
exemplaires ouais donc c'est pas ce fait
ni pour eux ni pour moi quoi moi parce
que j'ai pas tricher ils ont ils ont
tous eu de percuter au seuil tout de
suite directement c'est tout de suite
s'ils m'ont pas mis les menottes
non je déconne de la callas quoi ouais
c'est de la main alors vous avez signé
le contrat aidé que vous aviez le chèque
en poche c'est vrai que vous avez
disparu le ter de joueurs partis way un
mois en angleterre m'enfin de la boxe
parce que je me suis dit c'est pas
possible
ils vont me rendre le chèque obligé
ouais immonot en me d'autre après
peut-être ils vont me le reprendre
en tous les cas là on rigole mais là
c'est un succès c'est un gros succès si
c'est pas fini mais vous êtes assez un
an
un en dur avait créé en anglais mais
j'ai mis 25 ans dont le rêve est quoi ce
sens qui laisse entrer ici où il est il
sait ce qu'il veut et ce qu'il sait où
il va danser bien vous l'avez vu
d'autres chèques tu veux d'autres chaque
chrétien occasion d'essai du silex a
fait des étincelles
vous avez crié que chez vous chez vous
quand vous l'écriviez on vous disais
mais qu'est ce tu fais tout à toute la
journée dans ta chambre travers ce
bouquin disons qu est ce qui s'est passé
ce qui évidemment pour des gars comme
enfermé natation pendant pendant une
piste ça fait un peu bizarre dans la
tête des neurones de nos parents quoi
moi et donc ils ont été un peu ça a été
un peu bizarre pour eux quoi mais au
final j'ai écrit beaucoup dans ma
chambre énormément aussi à l'institut du
monde arabe et beaucoup de temps d'entre
métrage est ce à dire dans le terreau
verts dans leur beaucoup dans le rer
c'est à dire l'autre enfin bon je vais
pas déjà mais ce film est l'autre
histoire
tout est écrit dans le rer ouais ouais
voyez notre histoire encore il faut pas
dire alors quand on vous demande
pourquoi vous avez écrit ce livre vous
dites pour prouver que les gens comme
moi qu'on regarde comme des pitbulls ont
une sensibilité loyer mais en même temps
on a aussi des morsures qui égale celle
des pitbulls
ouais ok c'est l'instant il ya du
respect et de les couteaux et labour ont
balancé des émotions comme là quand je
te regarde
mais dès l'instant où il ya l'agression
on est laboureur vont répliquer c'est
toute notre culture mais sensibilité oui
pitbull non mais c'est quand même tm qui
a fait la préface quoi me sens un beau
cadeau pour moi parce que pour moi c'est
comme elles viennent des mec pas très
fréquentable quand même
disons que pour toi pour toi et je les
rencontre à une fois devant la maison de
disques sony la fin il me mettre en
morceaux martin muscle et c'était pareil
c'est habillée en hôtesse de l'air enfin
je vais pas revenir sur un thème parce
qu'en même temps c'est tellement de
facilité de rebondir là dessus donnez
moi je t'en prie mais pour moi ce sont
des grands frères quand j'étais gamin et
qu'on avait une petite télé noir et
blanc c'est bien eux qui revendiquait
nos émotions enfin en tout cas les
miennes et aujourd'hui je suis content
d'avoir d'avoir fusionné qui me fasse la
préface du livre où quelques gaullistes
de gauche
ntn ça vous choque quand même quand ils
disposent bien faire des sacrifices vous
voulez mais bien sûr vous allez dire oui
mais tout le monde va dire oui parce que
la question est tellement facile je suis
pas là pour défendre le suprême je suis
là pour revendiquer mon livre il n'y a
pas de problème hautement revendique à
bhl alors vous avez une attitude quand
même rassuré oui il faut aller plus loin
que la question c'est vrai il y avait
pas la réalité mais ça ne choque tout le
monde puis quand il est là ça choque
plus mais non justement c'est pour cela
que j'insiste vous vous prenez une
chanson de ntm et vous remplacez flic
par juif ou par arabe qui vous lisent et
puis vous voyez les faits que vous
faites ou bien caramel
voilà parce que moi je lui donne
l'impression d'être le seul qui ait
choqué par un témoin je ne pense rien
faut faire précis ça je je ne pense rien
je trouve que tout est bien
ah bon j'aime j'aime bien tm j'aime bien
son livre je vous aime bien j'aime bien
vu qu'il ya pas manifester aussi solar
d'après ce que j'ai pu entendre sur le
4e canton des bouches de la wii parce
que ma vie et funky ce soir par exemple
j'ai l'opportunité d'aller voir
dieudonné ça monsieur que je respecte
énormément et pour moi voilà quoi j'ai
vers les gens qui me sensibilise il est
venu vers moi donc je suis flatté toile
mais vraiment enfin ensuite tu vas vers
un verre inter parce que là ça bah quoi
audi voté pour emmerder vos skis la 7e
qui parraine ntm qui compte c'est 6 de
faim boucle son bouquin et technique est
là on la dernière fois mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que canto quand on parle
d'un thème ici généralement tout le
monde doit quand même ils exagèrent de
casser la gueule à des hôtesses de l'air
il ce soir yann moix a l'air de chocolat
limité
une hôtesse de l'air mais c'est sa femme
surtout peut-être ce qui se passe si tu
veux et je vais écrire un livre sur un
personnage qui ressemble le rapt est
radio et ça te fera plaisir
d'interviewer dessus mais là ces bunkers
d'accord sarine rudin c'était un [ __ ]
oui c'est un écrivain lui toute façon il
a fait noter m a fait la préface alors
en même temps sur la sur la vie des
cités sur la rue dit quand même que il
faut se prendre en main et qui a pas de
place pour les pleureuses
c'est que les intéressant d'en venir
masquer ce qui se passe aujourd'hui est
et ce qui se déroule depuis de longues
années jean depuis de longues années ce
qui se passe
jean lemay qui s'écoute quand il parle
de hockey c'est que effectivement on a
cru aux jeunes que il fallait
revendiquer ou casser la mairie pour
obtenir
moi je dis c'est une chose mais la
meilleure des choses c'est de te prendre
en main quoi qu'il arrive il faut lutter
pour tes propres émotions bon il faut
aller de l'avant en quoi il faut arrêter
que de quoi que il ya des barrières rien
et tu peux pas tout attrapé il faut
rêver tout est possible je n'en pas tout
est possible
moi je les fais ça a été du travail tout
et du travail mais il faut rêver vers
son travail et ça peut s'obtenir
peut-être et quand vous dites pas du
travail j'entends attention justement ce
qui est étonnant dans discours de rachid
djaïdani c'est que il en parle du faux
cependant main il dit le problème de la
banlieue c'est avant tout une histoire
de frustration sexuelle
c'est des choses qu'on entend rarement
ça et c'est vrai mais c'est aussi une
réalité on est toujours en meute
donc quand on a besoin d'une fille qu'on
se retrouve à 15 on l'abordé forcément
ça fait assez
non ça fait émeutes
vous dites si l'état montre ses
faiblesses a aussi d'encore plus je
dirais non pas politiquement correct
mais presque enfin train tout cas plus
étonnant si l'état montre ses faiblesses
plus la tentation est grande pour les
jeunes de montrer les crocs bah ouais tu
vois des policiers enfin on n'est pas là
vous faussez drôle que moi aujourd'hui
je suis amené à parler de ça alors que
j'ai même pas fait les études qui
peuvent revendiquer que je puisse en
parler
jamais le coup d'oeil on va se lâcher
c'est l'école buissonnière ce soir voilà
regarde ce qui est ce qui est assez
drôle c'est qu'aujourd'hui les policiers
dans tous les documentaires qu'on peut
voir la télé ou ailleurs ils n'arrêtent
pas de paul pleurer revendiquer qu'ils
ont passé le matériel revendiquer que
c'est dur revendiquer ceux ci ont
revendiqué à regarder les jeunes lancent
des cailloux manie toi tu es jeune tu
vois un policier s'est froissé fragile
sensible donc c'est un homme donc
forcément tu feras qu'associé ça ça ça
donne de l'eau au moulin on va dire ça
t'aide à faire le geste un peu trop fait
ensuite recule finalement ça donne envie
de lui taper dessus qua non si le flic
pleurs oui ok ça donne envie pas
forcément lui donner des kleenex mais il
se tient en fin de compte n'a pas choisi
la bonne voie
ouais donc passe de l'autre côté couet
flic ou voyou quoi pascal légitimus mais
j'adhère à ce qu'il dit de toute façon
c'est il dit des choses tellement vrai
loyalement commentant rarement ben oui
mais il ya des humoristes qui elle l a
fait il ya beaucoup de vrai ce qu'ils
disent des choses mais c'est faux s'est
fait sous la forme du mouche demoiselle
qui parlent de choses quand même assez
grave
la base de l'humour c'est dire des
choses g est un peu décalé il sauf que
lui le 17 les premières en parler c'est
ça d'une part lui c'est le deuxième mais
bon voilà
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que on
permet aujourd'hui à ce monsieur d'en
parler à la libé à 5-6 ans était un peu
fini avec les inconnus ou des parodies
de citer tout à fait parce que pour nous
c'est un phénomène tellement fort à
l'époque que maintenant c'est devenu
banal mais à l'époque savoureuse nous
choquer et positivement de voir des
jeunes qui avaient envie de ses prix à
travers une musique à travers des choses
comme ça exactement ce que je veux dire
chose que je veux signaler c'est que ce
que ce qu'ont fait les uns les inconnus
par exemple ça a jamais joué contre les
mailles du quartier
alors qu'aujourd'hui a beaucoup
d'humoristes on va pas les citer mais
bref cette façon je suis pas l'amour
pour faire la guerre même si elle fait
que commencer
ok c'est que il y en a beaucoup qui ont
trouvé la facilité de faire un accent
voisine un rythme en mer comment on fait
et ça fait rire tout le monde dans la
salle moines message aux autres nous
quoi la différence c'est que nous on
aime nos personnages c'est important
dans la compassion pour les personnages
que que l'on qu'on égratigne un petit
peu ça c'est important sinon ça devient
de la vengeance personnelle et c'est
vrai que c'est pas très sain mais c'est
qu'ils y mourir sur scène qui font ça à
vous ma vitre est votre radio du régime
une espèce de marketing de la révolte
moi je me suis moqué d'amendé respect
c'est se moquer des gens qui disaient
aux états mais je trouve ça tellement
tellement enfin ctc pour faire jeune
j'aime pas le jeunisme je n'aime pas
qu'on veuille faire jeune à tout prix
qu'on veuille être marche dans le sens
du poil aboyer avec les loups alors
aussi de boue j'ai fait de la boxe avant
de la plus belle chose qui me soit
arrivée dans ma vie et
et c'est un métier tellement magnifique
vous êtes le ring m'a donné le goût du
combat je suis un guerrier je
n'abandonne jamais pensé que ça vous a
ben disons que ça te fait comprendre que
la vie c'est comme le ring c'est à dire
il n'ya pas de plage rebondit sur ce que
j'ai écrit il ya pas de place pour les
pleureuses qui serre les dents tu vas en
avant et tant que la décision n'est pas
donné il faut pas lâcher
quoi qu'il arrive mais voilà chez parmi
les jeunes des cités de banlieue et
mâcon bien comme ça qu'ils disent pour
qu'on s'intègre il faut qu'on y arrive
il faut nous on a ri c'est ça que je
veux faire signaler on arrive et c'est
pour ça que j'ai dit ça fait que
commencer le compte de la place ça veut
dire ça veut dire que on est là et
maintenant vous aussi goûté au gâteau
quoi allez vous avez donné maintenant on
a un peu de votre salaire que ça soit
une bonne idée
j'ai pas de questions posées messieurs
après la guerre shit c'est bien là bien
sûr d'en attendre près d'une par
ailleurs la saison prochaine
alors vous avez fait beaucoup de clips
vous avez fait des séries là vous faites
à 1 le rôle principal dans un an mais
tracé sur une superbe aventure qui se
déroule vraiment effectivement grâce
grâce à ce bébé quoi ouais c'est à dire
je travaille sur un film
loin des sentiers de la racaille séduire
le personnage n'est pas vas-y la vie de
ma mère et la comédienne point je peux
les citer ça dérange pas je le dérange
pas merci beaucoup c'est fabienne bad et
le réalisateur c'est jacky katu et puis
mon voyage
ils m'envoient que des bonnes choses et
que du positif et c'est bien parce que
moi j'ai pleuré
aujourd'hui les jeunes fois mais tu dois
être content mais c'est enfin je vais
pas refaire ouais c'était tellement dur
mais c'est une souffrance qu'on pleure
pas un saut je casse tout y'a pas de
problème pour ça non non non mais moi je
suis bien là il n'y a pas de problème
mais en même temps ça a été tellement
dur pour le pondre tellement dur bourbon
le faire c'est pas comme georges en
série le jeu ne sait trop qui à leur
petit qu est ce qu a fait aujourd'hui
ouais j'ai écrit une page tu vas là les
installeurs à nos amis ouais non nous
c'est ton père qui vient
qu'est ce qu'il fout là dedans tu te
rappelles écrit encore qu'est-ce qui se
passe tu vas tu veux répondre les
poussins là ou quoi
lève toi je suis travail talât je vous
racontais des points ne sais pas c'est
pas comme genre
tu as un ordinateur patate 1 bis qui
fonctionne bien
t'as du papier blanc n'en vas-y batwa
gao c'est un peu comme julien sorel à
640 rochers de l'île
et le succès de jamel debbouze est
magnifique mois déjà mais je les ai vus
jouer au tuyau lui qui avait vingt
personnes à la fin on pouvait lui faire
la bise quoi aujourd'hui qu'il va vous
la faire lui faire la bise souhaite
prendre un avion en coin vigie du monde
stopper 4
mais c'est super ce qui se passe quand
on pose la question quand tu imagines
que le guéry vient de trappes
il a il a grandi dans un quartier dans
une tour quoi et aujourd'hui il fait le
succès qu'il fait comme on dit abdoul
elah merci mon dieu pour lui quoi je
suis vraiment fier bros jamel je suis
vraiment fier pour tous les jeunes
qu'ils soient issus durable de la
littérature du cinéma qui s'en sortent
et sans baisser la france une question
djamel dit souvent dans ses interviews
qu'il est croyant est ce que nous soyons
mieux bien sûr toute façon nous on a
grandi dans cette culture ou la religion
est très importante parce que ça me
permet d'être face à toi et de pas
initiaux tu suis pas une [ __ ] quoi tu
vois aucune la voisine j'ai quelque
chose à dire
virginia où il disait que pour écrire il
fallait quelque argent et une chambre à
soi et il n'avait pas d'argent il
n'avait pas de chambre il a réussi à les
tenir à l'écart par la caméra soit
bunker de rachid djaïdani au seuil donc
à part les deux fautes d'orthographe que
l'éditeur a laissé c'est très bien mais
je la recommence et la tête